[ __ ] the first rule of adapting
something be don't tell a different
story than the one in the thing you're
adapting the little prince now I was
really looking forward to this Netflix
brought it to us after it didn't get a
theatrical release stateside and this
thing has gotten um rave reviews it's
like 93 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
something like that and I know I'd read
such great things about it boy boy was I
let down
okay now full disclosure before I get
too far into this my familiarity with
the source material the actual novella
the little prince is kind of spotty I've
never read a thing front to back I'm
very familiar with certain sections of
it but I have not read the original
thing the thing is though my problems
with this actually I I feel fully
justified in even though I haven't read
the book and I'll explain why in a
little bit more detail but basically
after I finished the movie I read a
synopsis of the book and confirmed my
suspicions about how little of the
actual book is in the movie so here's
the general overview the book the little
prince is a poetic lyrical your
metaphorical story about life and love
and death and holding on to curiosity
and finding the beauty and things and
listening to your heart the movie the
little prince is about how awesome the
story the little prince is and I'm not
even like exaggerating or being
facetious or being a jerk about it that
is literally what the movie is about so
the plot of the film is there is this
little girl who is about to start at
this new school that's this new really
prestigious and she's got a very you
know overly controlling mother her
mother means well but she's got her kids
schedule down literally to the minute
and you know to try and have her build
towards her perfect life for when she
grows up and they moved to a new house
and this little girl meets this neighbor
this bizarre weird quirky neighbor who's
this really old guy and he serves as the
narrator and he tells her the story of
the little prince and then the movie is
about how that story impact
sir but it doesn't actually really tell
the story of a little person well it
does it's in there most of it and you
can tell very clearly when they're
actually doing a little presence because
the visual style completely changes the
vast majority the movie is fairly
standard CGI it's sort of that you know
Pixar things worked I mean I'm not
saying it looks distinctly like those
but it's it's on that cupboards mind
there's nothing flashy about it but it's
not really supposed to be either when
they actually are telling the story of
the little prince it goes into the
stop-motion that is gorgeous
and simple yet beautiful and it's
wonderfully evocative of the story of
the little prince you know what my
experience from the sections that I
actually know of it and but oh my god
the signal will the Fox especially is
gorgeous and it's over like that and
it's back to CGI world with this girl
and this old guy where they beat every
single metaphor to death by literal
izing it as opposed to just letting a
stand and then they talked ad nauseam
about how important and impactful this
story was and is and everything it means
instead of just telling the story and
letting it be that I mean that this is
this is going to join you know things
like the the dr. Seuss adaptations that
they turn into feature films think you
know things like how the Grinch Stole
Christmas the one with Jim Carrey or the
Lorax animated movie where the things
that they did and I'm sure they'll
justify it in this is what we had to add
to Pat it out to make a feature-length
have like okay well first of all if you
have to add stuff that is that ancillary
then you know what make us short don't
adapt it to the feature-length okay
anyway moving on from that but like
those other movies it just pads it out
to a longer runtime and there's less and
less and less and less of the original
work as the thing goes on the only
reason this isn't quite as bad as those
movies is unlike those it does actually
recognize what is good about the
original story something like The Lorax
on the other hand seem to completely
miss the freaking point so it's not
quite as bad as those but wow this thing
is so pretentious
and self-congratulatory and you know
this is the kind of framing story I
should have been ok with because on
paper I love stories about stories I
love stories about the power of
storytelling and the importance of it I
love things like big fish it's why I
love Neil Gaiman's Sandman but this the
actual story that it's telling it
becomes such a footnote in this pad
itself on the back self-congratulatory
thing going on and on about here's the
start of the little prince wasn't it a
great story
weren't we brilliant sharing that story
with you aren't you so happy that we
share this with you yes
yeah for about the 15 minutes that you
were actually telling the story of the
little prince yes it was good I like I
even loved those segments but I honest I
haven't broken it down but I just got to
be at best 15 percent of the movie the
other hour 20 hour and a half whatever
is this framing story that the original
did not need it doesn't add all it does
is pad the runtime and it's just so full
of itself it infuriated me with every
passing minute in my mind I'm just it's
just going lower and lower and lower cuz
it burns through the actual little print
stuff by maybe 40 minutes in this is an
hour of 40 minute movie so the remaining
hour just my appreciation mode was just
steadily dropping the whole time now I
don't know if the bit that all the love
the scenes getting is coming from people
who have actually read the original are
just happy to get any sort of adaptation
of it or people who have never read the
original this is their first
introduction to it and you know there is
brilliant stuff to be had there and I
can't understand why you'd bite onto it
but that this framing thing which is
most of the movie
oh it's God's crap so those are my
thoughts on the little friends again
judging by things like your on tomato
score I might be the only person on the
planet who feels like this but man did
not like it have you seen it what were
your thoughts on it whatever they were
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks follow the counsel geek
podcast available
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned